[Music]  in order to get more creative i would  encourage young people to be not afraid  of making mistakes  it's okay to fail  while exploring a new trail of thought  know that usually there is more than one  solution to the problem  math is as much about posing problems as  problem-solving and at that point  creativity is noticing where there is  something worthwhile investigating as a  student in math i think it's important  to remember that  math isn't just like random symbols on  paper like math can mean something and  it's pretty powerful that you as a  student can build something that uses  math creativity in math isn't just about  being able to pluck numbers from the air  and like oh yes i know the solution it's  about  being able to use problems that help  with your daily life